now Katie as I saying very busy actress
May the 7th you're going to be on bbc2
in such a sorry Shakespeare adaptation
the hollow crown yeah there's you and
Dame Judi Dench yes who unfortunately
has put some leggings on her head I
don't quite terrible wardrobe
malfunction so it's you Judi Dench
Benedict Cumberbatch's in it yes yes yes
lovely Bennet I love the red yes oh
there he is
but that Brown was scary why don't scary
things that was terrifying because I had
somehow got to the age of 38 and never
done Shakespeare ever and you know this
I don't know if you're going to do it
you know you might as well and you're
given the opportunity but to arrive on
your first day on set and immediately I
have a have a scene with one of the
greatest yeah ever Shakespearean actor
you know Judi Dench is a bit you know
yeah does she give notes I'd take them
um she's absolutely heaven she's
peaceful
I mean she's gets wonderful and that
very you part of surreal evening was it
with Judi and Benedict in a pod did we
were in the middle of nowhere we've had
amazing locations and we were in this
pub and all having a bit of sovereign
I'm Benedict came in and Judi was down
and Judy's lovely friend and we all
Saturn and the daughter the little hall
joining the Pug opening up people sort
of people had clocked you know hope
there's Judy in augments as a big event
and and then a girl came in it's just
she was 16 and she came in and started
to cry sobbing sobbing and it turned out
that she was having in the hall next
door in the middle of nowhere a benedict
cumberbatch themed birthday party
you know the cake was Ben's face on it
and there he was so yeah that was a bit
winner with Judi Dench as a sort of side
note hi extraordinary I was aware was a
wonderful thing to see you know of
course he was brilliant because he's
lovely and and suddenly it was it was
just amazing
oh is that so her life was peaked at 60
yes
with Drew Barrymore she made the mistake
of giving me notes which I would you
take that was sort of artificial because
it was it not I was the actress playing
the front attendance woman yeah at the
same time I was an American actress
playing the British woman